Kember so there's no value in human life
they will rob you and if you resist in
the least they'll be gunned down with no
remorse they'll do it smiling I'm Ruben
Maina
president / fi Mac Latin America
you know we're going to have
demonstrations we know we're going to
have stoppages of strikes and so on its
how big how violent they are that are
still unpredictable this could be a
security nightmare to some of us to
others like me it's a challenge so the
misconceptions of these guys are nothing
but a security guard in a suit and tie
and it's not that there's much more
training going into it these folks that
are out here working are all top
professionals in their field
and they work to make sure that they
understand how criminal element in us
while they operate so we can get better
at protecting our people
we're looking for anything that maybe
out of the normal that we need to be
aware of see that van is pulling up next
to my protecting they may be just
curious when they see this type of
configuration but it's got dark since he
tried to cut us off
see the key is to at least be moving at
this speed constantly in motion in
Brazil it's very common to have a
blockade thrown in front of you to get
you to stop some type of roadblock or
assailant you come out all of a sudden
when it's weird
turn the wheel
and we cannot vote potential situation
the avoid being stopped being locked in
we'll be taking the helicopter out for
our protectees and take him to the next
site if you fail in this arena it could
cost you your life so we're not only
protecting our clients their families
and their company assets take the cost
was art